so well before
I would tell my students just ask you
know what would Manali say right now and
you you guys all have a pretty good
emulator of me right now yes and uh I
don't know if you know the programming
Paradigm of the rubber duckling where
you basically explain to the rubber
duckling that's just sitting there
exactly what you did with your code and
why you have a bug and just by the act
of explaining you'll kind of figure it
out yes I woke up one morning from a
dream where I was giving a lecture in
this Amphitheater and one of my friends
was basically giving me some deep
evolutionary Insight on how cancer
genomes and cancer cells evolve and I
woke up with a very elaborate discussion
that I was giving and a very elaborate
set of insights that he had
that I was projecting onto my friend in
my sleep and obviously this was my dream
so my own neurons were capable of doing
that but they only did that Under The
Prompt of you are now piyush Gupta
you are a professor in cancer genomics
you're an expert in that field what do
you say so I feel that we all have that
inside us that we have that capability
of basically saying I don't know what
the right thing is but let me ask my
virtual legs what would you do and
virtual X would say be kind I'm like oh
yes or something like that and even
though I myself might not be able to do
it unprompted
and uh the my favorite prompt is think
step by step and I'm like you know this
also works on my 10 year old
when he tries to solve a math equation
all in one step I know exactly what
mistake you'll make but if I prompt it
with oh please think step by step then
you sort of gets you in a mindset and I
think it's also part of the way that
Chachi PT was actually trained this
whole sort of human in the loop
reinforcement learning
has probably reinforced these types of
behaviors whereby having this feedback
loop you kind of aligned AI better to
the prompting opportunities by humans
yeah prompting human-like reasoning
steps the step-by-step kind of thinking
yeah but it does seem to be I suppose it
just puts a mirror to our own
capabilities and so we can be truly
impressed by our own cognitive
capabilities because the variety of what
you can try because we don't usually
have this kind of we can't play with our
own mind
rigorously
through python code right yeah so this
allows us to really play with
um all all of human wisdom and knowledge
or at least knowledge at our fingertips
and then mess with that little mind that
can think and speak in all kinds of ways
what's unique is that as I mentioned
earlier every one of us was trained by a
different subset of human culture
and jgbt was trained on all of it yeah
and the difference there is that it
probably has the ability to emulate
almost any every one of us yeah the fact
that you can figure out where that is in
cognitive behavioral space just by a few
prompts it's pretty impressive but the
fact that that exists somewhere is you
know absolutely beautiful and
the fact that it's encoded in an
orthogonal way from the knowledge I
think is also beautiful the fact that
somehow through these extreme
overparameterization of AI models it was
able to somehow figure out that context
knowledge and form are separable and
that you can sort of describe scientific
knowledge in a haiku in the form of I
don't know Shakespeare or something that
tells you something about the um the
decoupling and the decouplerability of
these types of aspects of human psyche
and that's part of the science of this
whole thing so these large language
models are you know days old
in terms of this kind of leap that
they've taken and it'll be interesting
to do this kind of analysis on them of
contact of the separation of context
form and knowledge where exactly does
that happen yeah there's already sort of
initial investigations but it's very
hard to figure out where is there a
particular uh parameter set of
parameters that are responsible for a
particular piece of knowledge or a
particular context or a particular style
speaking so with convolutional neural
networks interpretability had many good
advances because we can kind of
understand them there's a structure to
them there's a locality to them and we
can kind of understand the different
layers have different sort of ranges
that they're looking at so we can look
at activation features and basically see
where you know where does that
correspond to
with large language models
it's perhaps a little more complicated
but I think it's still achievable in the
sense that we could kind of ask well
what kind of prompts does this generate
if I sort of drop out this part of the
network then what happens and sort of
start getting at a language to even
describe these types of aspects of human
be behavioral psychology if you wish
from the spoken part in the language
part and the advantage of that is that
it might actually teach us something
about humans as well like you you know
we might not have words to describe
these types of aspects right now but
when somebody speaks in a particular way
it might remind us of a friend that we
know from here or there there and if we
had better language for describing that
these Concepts might become more
apparent in our own human psyche and
then we might be able to encode them
better in machines themselves I mean
both probably you and I
would have certain interests with the
base model would open Echo as the base
model which is before the the alignment
of the
reinforcement learning with human
feedback and and before the
AI safety based kind of censorship of
the model